[Applause]
[Music]
london
greatest city in the world
well used to be
that's all right ness
[Applause]
government's [ __ ] off
extremists are grabbing power
organized crimes slicing up the boroughs
the war dogs are out
and freedom's a bloody joke
but this ain't there london this is our
london
and there's a new power growing it's all
of us together
we're building a resistance
one recruits at a time
what's my favorite operative up to this
evening and no i never say that to the
others scouting talent badly so gob shut
eyes peeled yeah
i have no eyes and if i did i wouldn't
peel them
[Music]
bloody drones are everywhere kicking our
[ __ ] teeth in lately
then i recommend you recruit someone who
can deal with drones brilliant never
would have thought of that
you're clear shot off
right easy i'm complying
impressive skill set sure but we need a
drone expert raj not a [ __ ] kicker file
that one away for later
are you concerned about the inquiry
style being presence in london
it's a total disgrace mercenaries
patrolling the streets get the [ __ ] over
here me i ain't done nothing come on you
shifted frick hurry up well now
jimmy shaw no formal engineering
training but he has several mischief
charges for hijacking albion drones hold
still [ __ ] you man you got no right
get out of here
oh just ignore me
[Music]
not today
[Applause]
[Applause]
oh that's a checkpoint
[Applause]
[Music]
he's gone
lovely evening isn't it ah i used to
feed the birds here now they're all
bloody machines
get used to it in the long march of
progress everything dies eventually
eventually even you bagley i'm sure now
there's my helen speaking of death
you'll never guess what just happened to
ian oh for god's sake badly a little
respect then let's finish what he
started he was working on a new recruit
a drone expert that's promising what do
we know about him albion scans jimmy
just before ian was killed i should be
able to predict his next move from that
data unfortunately his records are
locked up tighter than your compression
stockings are they now
but this case should be handled by the
met
albion's even taken over scotland yard
[Music]
indicate that jimmy's gone to camden
market let's get someone over there
badly chop chop
[Music]
ready for some action naomi always for
this recruit better be worth all the
trouble
according to the scotland yard records
jimmy's sister was killed by clan kelly
we believe he's seeking his revenge
inside camden market camden black market
you mean
yes the kelly's a rumor to run all sorts
of illicit goods out of the old stables
some with fingers and toes
if he's gone in there alone he's in big
trouble kelly's have this place on full
lockdown
hmm
i have an idea
no today everything is all fine and done
hmm
[Music]
now naomi we've already lost one
operative so try not to get killed or
we'll be in the red for the day
i'll be that
[Music]
what the hell
is this a meme
this better be a joke
ah cannabis and fentanyl together at
last through the miracle of genetics
the kellys are moving loads of weapons
out here
i'm not your typical back alley shanks
stables it's human trafficking
[Music]
found jimmy
cheeky [ __ ]
[ __ ] you
and here we thought he might be in some
sort of trouble
lots of hugs and kisses
[Music]
[Music]
oh
wait a minute are you dead sick i hope
you're sharper than you look
jesus christ don't ever beat his dead
priests
that's the rolling help
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[ __ ] it out
[Music]
well we showed those [ __ ] didn't we
we almost died out there tonight look
thanks for helping me but i can handle
myself right you think you're better off
alone
you think everyone else has given up and
there's no one to trust
that's what they want you to think and
that's how they'll take us one at a time
it doesn't have to be that way
together we can change things
wait
what happened to that bloke who helped
me
he didn't make it
james yeah
okay so
where do i go to meet the rest of the
crew you don't need to go anywhere look
around you everyone has a reason to
fight and dedsec is open to anyone
anyone
welcome
to the resistance
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
thank you
guess i'm going to make you all wait so
long i should really knock it out of the
park huh
uh i'm clint hawking i'm the creative
director of watchdogs legion
and for the past few years the team and
i have had the privilege to work on a
game and an innovation that we are very
proud of
watchdogs legion is set in london
one of the greatest cities in the world
and it's had a massive influence on all
of our culture for centuries
today with brexit
london's at a turning point
it's hard to predict what the future
holds for london for the uk
or for the world
but history has proven time and again
that where london goes
all of us go together
in our near future london is facing her
downfall the uk has become a
surveillance state and freedom has been
replaced with fear
armed drones patrol the streets
deportation squads rip people from their
homes
and granddad is using crypto to buy a
new kidney on the black market
but londoners never surrender their
resilience and determination is an
inspiration to us all and they are the
heroes of our game
all of them
in watchdogs legion your mission is to
build a popular resistance to fight back
against the emergence of an
authoritarian regime this means you
don't just play as one hero but many
and in watchdog's legion you can recruit
and play
as anyone
[Music]
in our game
every londoner is fully simulated with a
persistent life and relationships and
anyone from the entire population can be
recruited into your team
find them profile them hack into their
lives play their origin mission and win
them over to your cause the heroes you
recruit are all unique characters with
different backstories and personalities
fully voiced and animated and they are
the stars of your story
every cinematic in the game will change
depending on whether you're playing a
former mi5 action hero a 70 year old
granny you saw feeding pigeons in the
park or anyone in between however you
want to play
whoever you want to be
watchdogs legion lets you be that
you want to make a team of classic
british spies no problem you want to be
a crew of street savvy kids from the
council block do it you want to go
hipster body mod afropunk gangsta
awesome
the women of bletchley park
these ladies [ __ ] invented hacking
play as anyone is the innovation that
transforms a story about freeing london
and the world from the grip of tyranny
into a game about the heroes that live
in each of us
because being a hero isn't just a job
for someone else anymore
it's a job for everyone
so on behalf of the watchdogs legions
team here and around the world
i hope to see you on the booth thank you
for your time and welcome to the
resistance
[Music]
ah london
had a good run there for a while
now it's all right
[Applause]
bombings
and people thrown in cages like animals
oh i know you could forget the killer
robots everywhere
so yeah that's all gonna be [ __ ]
[Applause]
it's up to us to take our city back
thing is we can't do it alone we need to
recruit a resistance
[Music]
i know what you're thinking where do we
start
open your eyes and take a look around
look here look at him
no not him
him
former mi5 duty never ends
he can get anywhere
and erase
anyone
see her let's kick those bastards out
london
she got kicked out of oxbridge robotics
school for teaching him to uh reproduce
[Music]
and that fella over there
proper belly come on come at me he'll
crack your skull just for looking then
funny
[Music]
this had better be [ __ ] good
and allow me to introduce you to the
deadliest of the long
she's not old she's experienced
like i said you can recruit anyone and
all me bloody anyone
him
her
everyone is a secret weapon
find them
recruit them
the resistance
[Music]
let's unfuck this world
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign